hey everyone well as you can guess the
foreigner closed alpha well closed last
weekend however we managed to run fight
kill die and decapitate and conquer our
way through a handful of hours with the
Alpha i'm still doing here's a top five
things we learned in for Honor's closed
alpha
right off the bat for honors with alpha
presented quite a surprising features
starting with three well crafted maps
from precedes castles two rather covered
stronghold two then flooded temples from
the land with the Rising Sun the amount
of detail shown in these maps puts them
center stage right alongside the heroes
and visual detail the size of these maps
worked really well given the fact that
the terrain your hero had to cross be it
the rooftop bridges or charging
headfirst into enemy lines given this
was a multiplayer only affair I at times
forgot I was playing a pvp or PVE bot
match given the presentation was so well
done that I found myself drawn into the
conflict right in front of me it would
have been interesting if you could
hinder your opponent's path to a capture
point via calling in an arrow barrage or
sending a bridge on fire either way for
first time impressions as these alphas
tend to be I'm very pleased with amount
of detail these maps had to offer and
here's hoping that the remaining maps
yet to be shown offer the same amount of
detail if not more in the coming months
to follow for Honor's februari release
what bar owners maps sharing their
beauty and player 2 objective path
balancing the same unfortunately kept
you set with the game's hero classes
balancing problems albeit this isn't
alpha after all so there is plenty of
time to fix these issues it needed to be
said that some of these heroes just
flat-out steamroll their competition it
became no surprise once players found
that the fast but as I oeg samurai or
the hit-and-run Viking Berserker with a
bee's knees when it came to racking up
the kill count these characters even the
most novice of hands can run circles
around their heavier foes such as the
hard-hitting Viking Raider or the long
sword wielding warden to name a few also
as you fight in each round you in-game
level up meaning you will mock perks you
can then use on your opponent's later in
battle the light armored classes unlock
perks make it just too damn easy to kill
other players a too frustrating to
counter yourself and you're not playing
as a light armored character fighting
another you can still rack up kills as
any character albeit through practice
but given a certain Hall of abilities
that lights have over the heavies it's
just too much of a one-sided affair
currently built into the game but since
this is an alpha here's hoping the devs
fix this problem soon
teamwork and any multiplayer based
platform can always determine the
outcome of any match from overwhelming
victory to close defeat moments however
hear that premise is so strong that even
if you're the slightest bit of a lone
wolf type then you may not find much
enjoyment here but if you're like me and
enjoy good squad based team tactics then
you're in for a treat for honor heavily
hints on pairing up from capturing
objectives clearing waves of henchmen to
push the lines forward to then coming to
the aid of outnumbered allies picking
you're balancing your squads heroes
plays a big part in the combat
coordination have a group made entirely
out of light or heavy heroes only then
be prepared to watch your lines fall
objectives loss and heroes cut down in
minutes the reason for a balanced team
is so that you can counter any situation
for honor players will throw at you for
example one situation could be you're
playing as a heavy hero versus another
both of you pack the punch but are just
too slow to attack the other effectively
however if your team chose wisely then
you can call them for some agile backup
that can harass your opponent give you
the times to pick the right moment to
strike a heavy blow finishing your enemy
off and one of the many gruesome
finishing moves each hero has in this
game senior team balanced and
coordinating on the field is easily one
of the most enjoyable moments I've had
so far here's hoping that you yourself
continues focusing on this as the
development continues down the line
the Alpha showcased three modes for us
to dive into all of which something
different in their own unique way duel
is a 1 verse 1 mode where both players
test their combat skills in a best of
all series of rounds brawl is a copy of
duel however with the twist you now have
two verse 2 with no barrier separating
you from your teammate over your
teammates opponent a well-crafted pair
can double team another opponent leading
to some clothes and exciting matches
that you would see straight out of the
movies speaking of living your own
heroic moving moments and for honor the
last mode is domination with its name
well deserved a 4 verse 4 mode with AI
controlled minions battle it out in a
king of the hill style affair this mode
is the piece de resistance of foreigners
offerings your seven samurai Braveheart
and kingdom of heaven moments will come
alive here and Hellfire combat as you
and your team fight for supremacy
against the other players pushing your
skills to the breaking point for me
domination umbrella fit perfectly
however duel got old really quick mostly
because the one verse one gets old fast
your special abilities that you unlock
and domination through combat that gave
your fights their own unique feel are
nowhere to be found here leading to a
rock-paper-scissors fight in a non
active environment sure will give you
your own Last Man Standing feel down
your spine for a while but given the
veracity of domination and the
nail-biting close moments of gras with a
friend duel just feels stale in
comparison with playing time to fix this
issue for Arnold could very well turn
this mode around which in my opinion it
desperately needs
what are the biggest surprises I got
from this game is how fun it is that you
can customize your hero from their
clothes or their combat stats when
you're here to be decked out in tattoos
and war-torn armor you can do that here
in surprising detail it's not
mind-blowing by any means but really a
neat feature the best part is that you
can power up your character to fit your
play style want to hero with high attack
damage but it can move like the wind or
do you want to hear that carves up your
enemies but can take the punishment to
how you play can be directed to your
hero stats each upgrade however does
come with a downgrade to another ability
meaning you'll have to build wisely but
also leads to a fair hero encounters
without any loadouts dominating another
I really hope to push further into this
field because this easily can make the
difference on the longevity of this game
as more and more titles or launch later
next year at the end of the day for
owner surprised the hell out of me I
went to the Alpha with an open mind and
got blown away for an alpha the issues I
had can and hopefully we'll get a dress
in the coming months but as it holds
right now for honor has a very bright
future for those looking to live up
there warrior dreams of conquest with
friends what would you like to see more
of from for honor in the near future do
you agree or disagree with what was said
here about for honor please share your
thoughts below and until next time keep
it here on gamespot for more on your
favorite games
you